[MUSIC]
[BLANK_AUDIO]
Hello, this is Allison Davis at Stanford
Graduate School of Business.
Welcome to our webinar on the Master's in
Electrical Engineering and
MBA Joint Degree Program.
We are going to be together here for 45
minutes.
And thank you to so many of you who sent
questions in advance.
We will do our best to answer as many
questions as we can.
I'm here with my colleagues from the other
parts of the Graduate School of Business
as well as the Engineering School, so we
have a great panel here today.
Becky Charvat, who's Associate Director of
the Career Management Center, Jack Edwards
who is the Director of Financial Aid at
the Graduate School of Business.
Katy Klamme who is the Associate Director
of Graduate Admissions at
School of Engineering department of
electrical engineering and
Mary Oleksy who is the Associate Director
at the Graduate School of Business for
the joint and dual degree programs.
And I'm particularly going to point out
Mary because she will,
if you do this Joint Degree Program, will
really become your new best friend because
she's the person at the graduate school of
business who advises students
as they make their way through the two
degrees.
And we, as you may know this is one of
several joint degrees that,
that Stanford offers as we are a big, big
believer in interdisciplinary education.
So I'm gonna start with Mary and asking
you Mary this is a new joint degree.
why, why is Stanford offering this degree?
What is the purpose and the value of it?
>> Hi everybody and welcome again, this is
Mary Oleksy and in regards to why we're
offering this joint degree, I think it's
for several reasons.
Stanford is known, well known for being an
incubator for new technology ventures.
And this new degree program is designed to
foster that innovation that springs
naturally from two of the universities'
world-class programs.
Namely, the Graduate School of Business
and the Electrical Engineering department.
The purpose of the program is to provide
an opportunity for electrical engineers
to develop the necessary skills to become
managers and entrepreneurs.
And, for technologically inclined business
students,
to gain a solid background in Electrical
Engineering by coordinating both of
these degrees in a more focused approach.
And so, for students that are admitted
into the Joint Degree Program,
they should be able to complete the degree
within nine quarters.
Which equates to a savings of
approximately two quarters since
on their own the, GSB takes six quarters
to complete the MBA and
the Electrical Engineering MS takes
approximately five to six quarters.
>> Great, thank you, Mary.
And for both Katy who's the Graduate
Admissions Director
from Engineering and again from Mary.
Who is this joint degree really meant for?
Who is the ideal candidate for this?
>> thanks.
This is Katy Klamme speaking.
I think for the ideal candidate, we're
really looking for
someone that has a strong technical
background.
Someone that also likes to think really
about the big picture.
So these are students who want to go
beyond the technical aspects of
their jobs and really have a vision for
how they want to
use the technical knowledge that they have
to really make an impact.
I think in many ways you can think about
it as, you know, in a marriage between
the technology and engineering side and
the business side of the industry.
>> Mary, any comment?
>> I think Katy covered it perfectly.
And, you know, we're hearing from
engineers that know they're eventually
going to be managing people and they want
to make sure they're well equipped for
those challenges that come along with
leadership and
management responsibilities.
>> Becky from the career end of of it,
what would be the career opportunities and
career paths for
students who are participating who are
pursuing the joint degree?
>> Definitely, thank you.
Yes, this is Becky Charvat.
I work in the Career Management Center and
lead the employee relations in the
recruiting team.
And what we're seeing constantly are,
well, is an increasing percentage of
students who want to pursue tech careers,
whether they're accelerating or switching
into a tech career.
And what we find is that a lot of these
companies want people with
a technical background.
So if you're someone who hasn't had that
in the past and you obviously
are interested in pursuing MBA, having the
joint degree with Electrical Engineering,
is highly valuable because you're gaining
that analytical mindset.
You're gain those technical skills.
And you're able to approach these
technical careers,
which may not seem as technical on the
surface when you here product management.
You think about it maybe on the high level
more, the leadership opportunity or
maybe as almost your own mini CEO-type
role managing the product.
But in fact, you know, when you dri, drill
that into it,
you're gonna be working with many
engineers.
And you're going to, maybe not necessarily
code every single day, but you're gonna
wanna be able to have that credibility
with the people that you're working with.
And having that technical skill set in
con, in conjunction with
the business leadership skill set is
highly valuable to a lot of employers.
So again, this past year we saw 32% of our
students go into tech
with 18% of the students going into, or
basically an early stage startup.
And a lot of those roles would, you know,
the companies are really looking for
that technical background, so the joint
degree would be a,
a huge asset from that perspective.
>> So its really an asset not only for
people who are going in
to technical companies but for many
students who are interested in,
in doing their own venture who are going
to become entrepreneurs.
>> Absolutely, yeah, from a from an
entrepreneurship perspective, it's
probably almost even more more valuable
because if you're setting something up,
and work, you could be working from the
business side.
And working with a technical co-founder.
Or you're doing you know, the coding and
the development yourself.
Then having that analytical side would
also be a really huge asset as well.
>> So do you think, Becky, does that mean
that, that the opportunities are really
just in Silicon Valley for people doing
this joint degree?
>> No.
I mean, we're seeing kind of the,
the Silicon everything going around the
world.
So you've probably heard of Silicon Beach
in Los Angeles.
You've heard of Silicon Alley in New York.
Now Austin has a booming tech scene, and,
of course, all around the world.
So, we're seeing growth in China.
We're seeing growth in Singapore.
We're seeing growth in London, across
Europe so they're really at, I mean, the,
the locations are pretty much endless with
the Silicon fill in the blank so
I do think that it's highly valuable
around the world.
>> All right.
Mary, back to you.
In terms of the structure of the program
and the sequence,
when would a student be at which school
and how many units would they be taking?
>> Sure.
So let me start by focusing my answer
towards people that are not yet
enrolled in either program.
So this would be for brand new people.
You can start with either program.
If you start at the GSB,
your first year you would be primarily be
taking GSB coursework.
So MBA courses.
And would probably have room for
about one to three Electrical Engineering
courses if you desire to take them.
And then your second and
third years would be a blend of Electrical
Engineering and MBA courses.
And you could choose what blend you wanted
to do.
So you could primarily in one quarter be
heavy on Electrical Engineering or
heavy on MBA coursework.
So there's a lot of flexibility.
If you were to start at the Electrical
Engineering program,
you would spend your first year primarily
focused on Electrical Engineering courses.
And if you wished, you could probably take
a small number of GSB electives.
And then your second year, you would be
almost completely at the GSB.
And again, you would have that option to
take maybe one to three
courses in Electrical Engineering and
then your third year would be a blend of
electrical engineering and MBA courses.
So overall, as far as units this joint
degree requires 84 GSB units.
And 45 MS units in Electrical Engineering
for a total of 129.
And the number of units you're going to
take per quarter is really going to
vary depending on what program you're
leaning more heavily into.
So at the GSB, students tend to take a
higher course load.
And over at Electrical Engineering, the
students tend to take a lower number of
units per quarter, just due to the
technical nature and
hours required outside of the classroom to
complete the work.
But we are pretty confident that students
should be able to
complete the full joint degree in nine
quarters.
>> And so, if GSB students averages 18
units a quarter, what would you say,
on average, at Electrical Engineering?
>> So if a student is in our MS in EE
program,
the students are primarily going to be
taking eight to ten units.
Which is about three classes.
Most classes in EE are three units.
Which requires anywhere from to 10 to 15
hours of homework or
coursework group work outside of the
classroom.
So it is pretty intensive per class in
terms of the hours.
Students that are in that joint program,
they will probably need to do one or
potentially more quarters at that 11 to 18
unit course load.
>> Okay.
Now we know that all of you on the line
are,
are here because you are interested in the
Joint Degree Program.
But after researching it, you may find
it's not something you want to pursue.
If that's the case Mary, can't GSB
students take some classes over
at the Engineering school even if they are
not enrolled in the Joint Degree Program?
>> Yes.
That's a great question.
So built into our MBA degree requirements,
students can take up 15 units of
university courses.
And so, sometimes it's a better fit for
students to really just take an area
of focus, and so they'll take 15 units of
coursework in one particular area.
So in this case it's, could certainly be
Electrical Engineering and
that would all count towards your MBA
degree.
>> Okay.
And Katy can Master's and Engineering
students,
I believe, they can take classes at
business school, is that true?
>> Yeah.
There are a number of classes that they
are eligible to take and there certainly
are also outside classroom opportunities.
We've had a long standing history of
students working together both
with startups or in clubs and other
organizations going back and
forth between the GSB and the EE
department.
So, aside from taking the class work,
there are a number of other opportunities
for students to really engage with the GSB
students as well.
>> All right.
Well, let's talk about the application
requirements and the application process.
You do apply separately to the two
schools.
And let's start with the application
deadlines and
I'll just say that for School of
Engineering there's one deadline,
which I believe is December 15th.
Is that right, Katy?
>> December 9th.
Okay.
December 9th 2014.
So one deadline.
Now what makes it a little complicated is
for the business school,
there are three deadlines that you have to
choose from.
So you can apply in October or January or
April.
We would suggest, however, that if you're
applying to the joint degree and
you are not currently a Stanford student,
we would highly encourage you to apply in
the second round.
And the reason for that is that you know,
you could apply in the first round but
you wouldn't know yet you wouldn't get
your decision back from
Electrical Engineering before the deadline
to respond to your MBA offer.
And conversely you can apply in the third
round but you wouldn't
know your GSB offer before you had to
reply to School of Engineering's offer.
So if you want complete information and
know if you got into both schools in order
to make your decision to come to Stanford,
the best round for you would be round two.
Now if you're a current Master's in
Engineering School student,
then you could really apply in any round.
>> Yeah.
>> So any, any of those three rounds.
For the business school the application
requirements are as follows.
We require a transcript.
We do require the the standardized test.
But again, if you're applying to the Joint
Degree Program,
you would want to take the GRE and not the
GMAT.
Because the School of Engineering does not
accept the GMAT.
So if you're looking at the joint degree,
please save yourself some time and
take only the GRE.
If you are an international student and
you went to school where the language of
instruction was not English,
then you do need to take one of the
English language tests.
But again School of Engineering will only
accept the TOEFL.
So if you're applying to the Joint Degree
Program again, save yourself some time and
just take the TOEFL.
Although the Business School will accept
some of the other English language tests.
We also at the Business School require two
recommendations.
And your first recommendation must come
from a current direct
supervisor at work, and if you don't have
work experience that could be from an
internship or a summer job.
Your second letter of reference,
you have a choice of either choosing
another supervisor.
If we scroll down here, you can see, you
can chose another supervisor or
you can chose a peer.
Which is a person who's worked, you know,
on a, on a team with you.
The work experience I wanna mention.
We do not require work experience to,
to come to Stanford in the, in the
Business School.
So you can apply as a college senior and
if you are admitted, you actually have the
luxury of, of
being able to decide if you want to come
immediately after you graduate college.
Or we do offer deferrals to college
seniors of one or two or three years.
We also ask you about extracurricular
activities, if you have them.
And lastly, there's two essay questions.
What matters most to you and why, and why
Stanford?
Katy, what about for
Engineering, can you please walk us
through the application requirements?
>> Sure, so for EE,
we have an annual admissions process with
one deadline, as Allison mentioned.
This year that deadline will be December
9th.
And students that are applying during the
annual process,
they are admitted to start in autumn
quarter.
So students that meet that December 9th
deadline will be applying for
admission to start in September 2015.
Again no work experience is required.
Many of our students do have some work
experience any where
from one to four years usually on average.
To be eligible to apply to the MS in
Electrical Engineering,
students must hold a four years bachelors
degree from a credited institution and
that's a requirement from Stanford.
Almost all of our students that are
admitted do come from a STEM,
science, technology, engineering, or math
or hard sciences background.
Although it is not required.
There are also no prerequisites in terms
of specific classes.
But our students do need to have a very
strong foundation in engineering and
specifically in electrical engineering is
strongly recommended.
Because this is a rigorous academic
program, your application should
really showcase your propensity for
graduate level study in EE at Stanford.
So you'll find a list of all of our
application requirements on our website.
And I'm not gonna go through each of the
individual requirements.
But there are a few that I do wanna
highlight.
Specifically the GPA and GRE, so
one of our most frequently asked questions
is, is there a minimum for the GPA or GRE?
No, there is no minimum, typically our
students that are admitted tend
to be in the top ranks of their
undergraduate classes, and
then also in the top percentile of the
GRE.
We don't have an average in terms of our
admitted students for the GRE,
however typically our successful
applicants are in the 90th percentile or
higher on the quantitative section of the
GRE.
Again, that's not an average, it's not a
minimum or a requirement,
it's just something that we typically see
in our successful applicants.
Also wanted to discuss the letter of
recommendation.
So we require a minimum and maximum of
three letters of recommendation.
And these should really be coming from
academic references.
So people that can speak to your aptitude
for graduate studies.
Former advisors, professors, researchers.
That have really work with you in an
academic setting.
So, this is one of those differences
between the GSB and our application.
So, something to really take note of.
>> And any essays?
>> Yes, we do have a statement of purpose.
And it's just a very general statement of
purpose.
And that's your opportunity to discuss how
you're prepared for graduate study.
What you wanna do.
Your career aspirations.
And again, we're really looking for, what
is your aptitude for
graduate study in the EE at Stanford?
And so that's something you wanna really
showcase and
pull out throughout your entire
application.
>> And I should mention for the GSB, this
is Alison again,
that we also don't have a minimum GPA or
GMAT or GRE score.
And for the GPA, we're really looking at
your academic performance in
the context of the rigor of the
institution and the rigor of your majors.
Katy, I do want to ask you cuz we have,
did have several questions come in.
If somebody does not have a STEM
undergraduate major,
are there certain courses that they could
be taking in advance to prepare to,
to make themselves more competitive as an
applicant for Engineering?
>> Sure, there aren't any specifics
classes and
like I said, we don't have any
prerequisites.
Usually what I tell students that are
looking to apply and
that don't come from that traditional STEM
background.
Something to do on that will be able to
give you a little bit more perspective is
to take a look at Stanford's Explore
courses.
And if you go ahead and find the
Electrical Engineering department,
this is a list of all the classes that are
offered in EE.
And you can categorize them by different
quarters.
Most of the graduate level courses,
our students are going to be taking
classes at the 200 level or higher.
And so what we recommend that prospective
students do is to take a look at
those 200-level courses and see what the
prerequisites for the class are.
Now the prerequisites for each class are
determined by the faculty member.
And you may have taken a very similar
class, an undergrad.
And feel free to email the faculty member
and say hey,
I took this class in undergrad.
It sounds very similar to the
pre-requisite for your class.
Would this be appropriate or
do I really need to take the course here
that you've recommended at Stanford?
And that's a really good way to gage
whether or
not you're prepared to take these classes.
Because the program is so compacted and it
is so dense.
You really don't have time to be taking a
lot of those prerequisite classes.
You wanna be able to jump right in and
start taking those 200 level classes for
the Master's degree.
So I think that's really a great way to
kind of gauge where you're at
if you don't come from that STEM
background.
>> Thank you.
I know we have some current Stanford
students who are interested in
the Joint Degree Program, so Mary,
I'm gonna have you address for current MBA
students what they need to know.
And then Katy for current Master's of
Engineering or incoming Master's of
Engineering students what they would need
to know to apply for the joint degree.
>> So if you are a current or incoming MBA
student, you should apply for
the Electrical Engineering MS program this
year.
You need to do it during your MBA one year
if you did not do it
concurrently when you applied for the MBA.
>> All right.
>> Yeah, and the same case for those
current EE students that are out there,
you will need to be applying during that
first year,
second year students are not eligible to
apply.
And the only difference for the EE
students is
that you have the opportunity to apply at
any of those three deadlines.
Any of those first year GSB students that
are out there,
they need to meet the December 9th
deadline.
>> So just to be clear current second year
MBA students and current second
year MS EE students are not eligible to
apply for the Joint Degree Program.
But they could if they wanted just apply
to the other program and
do it sequentially one after the other.
>> That is correct.
>> Yeah that's correct.
>> All right, how are we gonna pay for all
of this?
I'm gonna turn it over to Jack Edwards to
talk about tuition and financial aid.
>> Hi folks.
Happy to talk to you today.
The tuition costs that you're going to be
paying,
you'll pay six quarters of GSB tuition.
Tuition is fixed for a two-year period, so
it's the same rate.
So the incoming class stay for the class
of 17,
which will be getting, the class of 16,
excuse me.
Their tuition as of right now is at
$61,875.
What's on the screen is the typical GSB
cost of attendance.
So if you're going to start the joint
degree, we recommend, I recommend from
a financial perspective, you're gonna want
to start at the GSB first because we
do offer financial aid for all three years
that you're in the program.
Your third year tuition will be billed at
the graduate rate for the university.
Which is a little bit less than what the
GSB tuition rate is.
>> And we-
>> Katy.
>> Yeah, we have that if we wanna go
ahead and navigate to the graduate
engineering tuition rates.
So any units, or any quarters that are
beyond the six GSB quarters of tuition
will be charged at the Stanford Graduate
Engineering tuition rates.
And that will either be at the end, eight
to ten unit rate, or
the 11 to 18 unit rate.
For 2014-15, the eight to ten unit rate
will be just over 10,000 or
about 30,000 for the entire academic year.
For the 11 to 18 unit rate it's about
15,000 per quarter.
Or about 47,000 or the entire academic
year.
And in the School of Engineering, the
academic year is Autumn, Winter and
Spring and then yeah for the six units of
GSB I'll go ahead and
turn it back over to Jack.
>> And for the six quarters of the GSB
tuition we don't
know what the incoming rate would be for
those that are starting in fall of 2015.
You can project, probably, about a 4%
increase in tuition costs.
And so for the two years that you're at
the GSB
rate, that'll be the same rate for both
years.
So, and the financial aid piece is,
financial aid at the GSB is determined
based on financial need, so
students have to demonstrate that through
submitting applications.
Domestic students will file the FAFSA plus
an ACFF profile application.
International students can file the CSS
profile.
W, our fellowship funds are either there's
no distinguish between being a domestic or
an international, if they thought that
need, so everybody qualifies based off of
what their application and their
individual information is.
Also we do have a loan program
specifically for our international
students as well, so that they have access
to loans that are competitive
interest rates, and information about that
is also on our website.
So you can do some research, and
you can see what types of aid are
completely available.
And so if you're in the Joint Degree
Program, you still will have access to
fellowship funds, as well as the student
loans at for your third year.
>> And again, this is if you were to start
at the GSB.
>> Right.
If you are coming,
if you are currently already in the MS EE
degree.
Your two years here, you would have access
to financial aid.
If you are admitted to the MBA program.
>> Okay.
And when you say financial aid you
mentioned loans and fellowships.
It's typically a combination.
I mean with one or two exceptions there's
really no full tuition fellowship.
>> No, there isn't the expectation of
that.
It's a combination of fellowships and
in the student loans we look at all of
your resources and your financial, and
determine your financial strength.
And we take that financial strength and
subtract it from what that total cost of
attendance that appears at the bottom of
the page, the total there, and
that determines a calculation.
[BLANK_AUDIO]
So there's the total amount.
So we look at that number and that's when
we do the calculation to determine.
See, it's a combination of both.
And so if you have external resources that
you may be bringing with you.
You may have a grant, you may have a
scholarship.
That is taken into consideration in the
calculation as well.
>> And when does the process occur, the
financial aid process?
So, depending on when you apply to the MBA
program in the rounds,
that's when you're gonna wanna take care
of applying for financial aid as well.
To be eligible for the fellowship you're
gonna wanna make sure that you're
applying by those deadlines.
There's a different deadline for each
round that you're admitted in.
>> This is after you're admitted.
>> After you're admitted to the MBA
program.
>> So first you would get your decision
hopefully from both schools in the-
>> Right.
>> And then you start the financial aid
process and
if you are completing all your paperwork
by the deadlines, you will have
a financial aid offer before you need to
accept your, your offer with the school.
So you'll have full information about your
financial aid offer before you have to
make a decision.
>> Correct one other reminder is that if
your a current MBA student whose on
receiving fellowship and, and for your
MBA.
And you're now applying to the Master's in
Electrical Engineering and
you get accepted there.
So you'll have one additional year, third
year, you'll be calculated for
eligibility for fellowship as well as.
>> Okay and I, I know some people in the
audience were alert to when I
said with one or two exceptions and are
probably wondering what those are.
Well the one or two exceptions is we do
have a full tuition scholarship for
citizens of India that's sponsored by
Reliance.
And we also have a full tuition
scholarship for citizens of Africa,
the Stanford Africa MBA fellowship and we
have had one person Mohammed,
ask, how does the Stanford Africa MBA
fellowship work with,
with the joint degree, if they were to
receive that fellowship?
>> The Stanford Africa MBA is strictly
just for two years.
We would recalculate you for eligibility
for fellowship for
the third year in a different format.
>> So.
>> But there is, there is eight available.
>> Okay, so you would still have access to
fellowships.
>> I wouldn't be up, yeah.
Right.
>> Funds for your third year.
>> Correct.
>> And the stanford Africa fellowship.
And this is true for the Reliance
Fellowship for Indian nationals.
It would pay for your first two years and
then you would.
Be eligible for financial aid for the
third year.
>> Yes.
>> Based on financial need.
>> Right.
All right.
So let's talk a little bit Becky and Katy,
about, what the opportunities are to
interact with Silicon Valley companies,
while you're a student here.
And also, just more generally, what
students do during the summer.
>> So I think that there are a number of
ways that students can get
connected with companies and internships
here in Silicon Valley.
I think many times students and other
people assume that it's our proximity to
Silicon Valley that sets Stanford EE apart
from other programs.
And while geographically, yes, it's great
it's right in our backyard.
It's really our history and
our partnership with Silicon Valley that
sets us apart.
Our faculty and students have, they played
a very key role in
founding Silicon Valley and continue to
shape what develops there.
So therefor many cases, our students are
connected with opportunities,
often through personal relationships, with
both our faculty and students.
But we also formally have many wonderful
resources on campus,
which include both the computer forum.
And we can go ahead and take a look at
their website.
The computer forum is a great organization
here on campus.
They are working specifically for students
that look to enter careers in
Electrical Engineering and computer
science.
They have over 60 members within Silicon
Valley and also worldwide,
they hold career fairs, resume workshops,
mock interviews.
They do site visits.
Really great opportunity.
And then, of course, we have Stanford's
Career Development Center.
And this is really more for a general
audience.
They have many of the traditional
resources.
Again, the career fair, the mock
interviews resume workshops.
But of course, this includes a very heavy
focus on CS and EE.
And they have dozens of connections with
companies and
opportunities here in Silicon Valley and
worldwide.
So that's a bit of the perspective from
the EE side.
Becky, do you want to talk about some of
the GSB side?
>> Sure.
>> Thanks.
Yes, so like Katy was saying, there's a
lot of opportunities at the GSB for
one to one connections, networking, that
sort of thing.
And we do a lot to facilitate that through
the Career Management Center.
We start off in the fall for full-time.
We have a very structured on-campus
recruiting process, so
if you decide you want to pursue a career
at a large tech company,
we have a large variety that come to
campus for on-campus recruiting,
everything from Apple, Google, Microsoft,
Amazon, Cisco, Intuit, you name it.
They're pretty much interacting with us.
But we also have companies such as
Dropbox, Box Facebook, LinkedIn.
These companies are coming to campus as
well for on-campus recruiting.
We have an internship program with, with
simila, similar list of companies.
Those companies come to recruit on campus
in the winter, so
in January for internship.
And that's our structured approach.
We put on several company networking
nights, where these companies will come
and basically, you know, mingle and
interact with students.
And get to know them and understand and
students get to
engage with those companies and understand
what opportunities both full time and
internship-wise they can pursue with those
companies.
In addition to that, we also host a number
of career treks.
So we organize trips.
One of them is called a Tech Crawl.
So envision, we call them, you know, for
those of you in the US, you may be
familiar with a pub crawl or a progressive
style dinner where students will be on
a bus and go from company to company and
meet at their offices in San Francisco.
Student clubs also organize similar treks
so
our Entrepreneurship Club as well as our
High Tech Club and a number of others will
also organize treks to companies around
the Bay Area as well as other locations.
So in the last two years, students have
organized a trek to Austin for
South by Southwest.
Where there's basically thousands of
companies to meet.
And the CMC, the Career Management Center,
also hosts an event called fewer than 300
or FT3, as we have abbreviated it.
In which we invite specifically companies,
about 30 companies,
which students have indicated of interest
to kind of
have a funky Silicon Valley-Stanford GSB
field event.
So we've had some pretty amazing startups
come to that event.
And we've had some pretty amazing
decorations and, and fun
interactions where students have actually
sourced full time jobs and internships.
So there's a whole slew of opportunities
with which to engage with companies.
>> Now for joint degree students who would
have two summers between their three
years, would they then be able to do a
summer internship again?
>> Absolutely, yeah, yes.
Well I guess from the GSP side, yes.
>> [LAUGH] Absolutely, I mean our students
are, they are very much encouraged,
right from the get go, to start planning
for that summer internship after their
first year and it would absolutely be the
case after that second year.
And I think Becky really, you know hit
the,
the point, you know, well that the
companies are coming here to Stanford and
our, the Stanford students really have a
great reputation rep,
representation out there in the sense that
you know, they're great students.
And these companies are really coming to
find our students.
They're seeking our students out.
And our students aren't going out there
and seeking out these internships.
But really, a lot of the opportunities are
coming to them.
I think that was something for me that was
really interesting to
see was to see these big companies, like
Google and Apple, showing up and
really sort of wining and dining our
students to see them for internships.
Another which often turns into those
full-time positions.
>> Right.
Yeah, I think there are many opportunities
in,
in a way, the challenge is to figure out
what you wanna do and
I think our career center does a great job
of helping you figure out what it is you
wanna do, not just in terms of your job
but how you're job fits into your life.
Would you say [CROSSTALK].
>> Absolutely, yes.
So we have a number of pro, a number of
programs.
Two in particular, one is called Career
Design.
Which first-year students at the GSB will
pursue.
It is basically it takes place in the
first six weeks of your time as
a first-year student here at the GSB.
And it basically allows you to take some
time to think about what it is that you're
interested in, what you're passionate
about, you know, what gets you going,
what do you want to do from a short term
and a long term perspective.
We have a program also called Career and
Life Vision, or
CLV, and this has a similar approach.
It's kind of a, a program within the
program.
That allows you to not only engage with
our with our career advisors who can help,
kind of, help you plan out your career and
life vision.
But, let's say you, you think you know
what you want to do but
you really need someone to talk through
that process with we have plenty of
people that are wonderful support staff to
help you with that.
So, there's a lot of opportunities to
explore.
>> And the Career Center is not only
helping you figure out what you want to
do, but prepare for
your job search, and interviewing skills,
all the way to when you get an offer, and
how to negotiate that salary all the way
to the end of, of the process.
In terms of social life for joint and dual
degree students as I, as I mentioned,
we have several other joint and dual
degree programs here so we do have a lot
of experience with Mary in particular with
working with joint degree students.
So Mary can you comment on,
what it is like for a joint degree student
in terms of social life?
Do they sort of feel like they're, you
know,
affiliated more with one school or
another?
>> Yeah.
That's a great question.
I think, first of all, it depends on what
program you start with.
And that you're going to build
relationships with the cohorts that
you're connected to.
So if you start at the GSB,
I think your going to feel most connected
to MBA students.
If you start in Electrical Engineering,
you're first going to build up kind of
your sense of community with those
Electrical Engineering students.
But what I have seen happen in other
programs is as
students start progressing through and
doing blended quarters.
They start to build up kind of the social
relationships in the other program.
And then they have what I like to call the
first world problem of having to
balance [LAUGH] the relationship that both
schools and
then all of the events and activities,
that're happening all across Stanford.
We're certainly not at a loss of things to
do, events to go to,
food to eat, music to hear [LAUGH].
Both here at Stanford and just in general
in the Bay Area.
So I think students find really rich
social life.
And sometimes you know,
part of the draw for wanting to stay for
an extra year is being able to
take advantage of everything that the Bay
Area and Stanford University has to offer.
Oh, and I also wanna add once you are
enrolled in a Joint Degree Program.
Let's say you start at Electrical
Engineering, but
you've been accepted to the MBA program.
You do have access to GSB student
activities and events.
And so you are very welcome to come here
and
to sign up for clubs and to attend
lectures, activities whatever you'd like.
So really the limitations are personal of
what you feel comfortable with pursuing or
not pursuing at your first year here.
>> And Katy are, are extra curricular and
clubs at Engineering opened to Business
School students in the same way?
>> Absolutely.
I mean I
think it depends on what you're most
interested in.
But we have a number of different clubs
that are specific to the research
areas within the EE.
We also have a group called the Graduate
Students in Electrical Engineering and
I know that they would more than welcome
students outside of
Electrical Engineering.
They do happy hours and they do workshops
with our faculty.
So students that are really interested in
getting engaged within EE would certain be
more than welcome to join us.
>> All right.
We only have a couple of minutes left, and
so I'm going to ask each of
you if you have any advice for our
prospective applicants out there,
either about preparing for the program, or
once they're a student here.
Katy?
>> Sure so I think I,
I could say I have two little pieces of
advice.
One would be to start planning early and
to get organized early on, if that's
possible.
And then my second piece of advice is
something that I actually recommend to
anyone that's applying to graduate
graduate school.
And that's to do informational interviews
with people that are in your dream job,
your dream field your dream career path
and
find out how they got to that position,
what degrees they have.
Also take a look at what they would be
looking at in terms of hiring somebody for
that position now.
Just to find out exactly what it is you do
need do you need the dual degree,
do you need the MBA, do you need a PhD or
do you need an MS degree?
And that again, is something that I would
recommend to anyone applying to
graduate school so
that you really hone in on what it is that
you need to achieve your career goals.
>> Great, Mary?
>> Well, I think Katy already said it
really well, but
what I would add is that I think there's a
lot of exciting options at Stanford, and
it's easy to get overwhelmed.
And so, any work you can do to get clear
on where you wanna go,
what you wanna do using some of the
strategies that Katy's
already mentioned I think are gonna come
in really handy.
I find that students who come in with a
vision, and that vision may change.
But hence, they have a vision, I think
they get more out of
their overall experience, because they
already have a sense of focus of what they
wanna say yes to and equally important,
what they should be saying no to.
Because there's just so
many things that you could be doing to
support your education.
So I would just say take that time to
really try to get clear,
even if it's a general vision, but to have
some type of vision.
Because the programs don't necessarily
help you find a vision.
The programs help you get to your vision.
>> Thank you.
Becky?
>> So I, I totally agree with what Mary
and Katy had said.
I was actually gonna talk about the
informational interviews with your dream,
people in your dream job as well.
So I, I'll get a little more tactical on
that front.
So this may seem you know, obvious to some
of you and for others it
maybe seem a little daunting, but I would
say in order to identify those people in
your dream job roles if you haven't done
so already, take advantage of LinkedIn.
You know, go ahead and plug in a company
where you want to work or
a function that you want to pursue at
those companies.
You can go into your advanced search in
Linkedn and just plug those things in and
see who comes up.
You can plug it in by region, so if your
specific to a location, you can add that,
and obviously it's, it's great to have
these meetings in person, but if you
can't, you know, Google Hangouts or Skype
even just 15, 20 minutes of someones time.
Be sure when you go into those
informationals, if it's over the phone or
in-person, have questions prepared in
advance,
be really thoughtful about what you want
to ask.
The worst thing that we see is when
students' asks for
informationals, a great contact, and they
show up,
and they haven't prepared or they haven't
done any research.
So, we know none of you will do that,
but make sure you know you have those
questions ready to go.
Keep your requests short and sweet, you
know, one to two,
max three sentences about what you wanna
ask for and then send a thank you.
So if you engage with these people who
have given you their time be sure to
send a follow-up thank you note,
even if it's just three sentences max
that, you know, wrapping up,
filling them in on where you're at in your
process, they'll really appreciate that.
>> Jack.
>> Think for financial aid perspective,
just, you can figure it out after you've
decided what's the best pursuit,
whether it's just an MBA, just an MS in
EE, or doing the joint degree.
>> And if we haven't made it clear earlier
you can apply to these
before you arrived for the Joint Degree
Program.
But you could if you only wanted to apply
for the MBA.
You could apply to the Engineering school
as a first year MBA student.
Or if you end up starting in Engineering,
you could apply for
the MBA and add it as a first year
Engineering student.
So you, you do have that chance to to take
some time to think about it.
Well I want to thank all of you for your
time this afternoon,
I hope that it's been helpful to learn
about the program,
and whatever you decide, I wish you all
the best.